I dunno a for people within Mercy sack
that have died either through family or
friends so it's real the Northwest has a
higher than average death rate and
Kensington in Liverpool is a place where
most people seem to know somebody who
died from covert 19 but even here the
national figure of 26,000 deaths is hard
to comprehend there is no one focal
point for the crisis in the UK no
disaster zone where we can lay flowers
so here is the story of just one life
lost the church warden at All Saints
Liverpool Bob Koren as soon as their
schools closed he started to develop in
quite a cough and he was just blaming it
on this seasonal cough that he used to
go over the winter and he was fine about
it he wasn't worried at all that you
know it was the virus he was saying I
recognize these symptoms it's you I've
had it before and he was reluctant to
seek help yeah and even the night before
he died he said I want to see how I am
in the morning I'll phone in the morning
[Music]
Bob died at home in bed his offer of
prayer for others still hangs on the
church notice board there are so many
families going through it and I'm glad
really that it's starting to be more
recognition that people are dying in the
community as well as in hospital because
for a time there was almost an anger in
me that not only had we lost him but he
wasn't being counted amongst the victims
but as someone who died at home although
kovat 19 is on his death certificate Bob
still doesn't form part of the revised
death toll figures because he wasn't
tested his loss though has rippled
through the community he was loved as a
cricket fanatic a church warden and a
school attendance officer
at some Michaels school where he worked
this is how children honored his passing
he was a man who gave to the community
and during the crisis delivered food
parcels to struggling families he was
such a lovely gentle man in the true
meaning of that word he had a real keen
eye for people who were struggling and
it it's a loss that I'm trying to
wrestle with if I'm honest father Coates
continues his work without his
right-hand man this is a community
that's good at coming together but
they're missing a man whose kindness
helped make that happen
Bob story will be mirrored across the
country in lots of towns and cities all
over the place where people are you know
quite viciously dragged out of their
community through covert and will be
hugely missed by families who will be
devastated by them and that's definitely
the case here you know bob was loved and
cared for us in a really deep way and
and we will miss him hugely and I don't
think we'll actually recognize that loss
properly until things settle down a bit
Jason Ferrell Sky News